on est quand même surpris et même
choqués de la méthode puisque vous avez
un abonnement qui a été voté après des
explications des échanges où le
gouvernement s'est exprimée s'est
expliqué et nous avons mené la bataille
pour faire passer l'amendement et qui a
été gagné un peu d'écart peut-être de
trois voies pour permettre aux
départements et régions de première de
pouvoir continuer à bénéficier de la
défiscalisation et pour le logement
social c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important à la fois pour des
logements neufs mais aussi pour la
réhabilitation 200 millions d'euros
globalement et revenir par le droit du
gouvernement à la deuxième délibération
qui est un petit des lignes démocratie
que vous avez gagné une bataille
parlementaire de manière transparente en
voulait limin à 5 heures du matin tu
vraiment pas sympa et pas bien les plus
belles au monde dit que ces systèmes
c'est toujours des explications
qui sont pas étayées et le score en plus
on sait qu'il n'ya pas eu beaucoup de
concertation sur ce thème là comme
d'ailleurs leurs battements riskalis
elle même reconnaît publiquement qui a
pas de concertation et parler
d'inefficacité s'ils n'ont pas très bien
connaître le dossier
parce qu'en gros la défiscalisation la
tendance était de remplacer la
défiscalisation par les crédits d'impôt
mais pour bénéficier du coni dépôt
bénéficier du que d'idées pour à la fin
du chantier par au début du chantier
bien un point de trésorerie alors les
sociétés hlm pourrait éventuellement
avoir de la trésorerie
mais quand vous avez des sociétés
privées ou des sociétés qui font le
logement social pour les plus
défavorisés et sans d'hébergement qui
font de la réhabilitation
c'est sociétés privées n'ont pas les
moyens d'avoir du prix financement note
la défiscalisation devient un moyen de
vous voir accompagner et le système du
crédit d'impôt est d'ailleurs on avait
fait passer un amendement précis qui
disait en attendant de mettre en place
le portage financier pour bénéficier du
crédit d'impôt il fallait absolument que
l'état le gouvernement garantisse la
mise en place du prix financement ce qui
était complètement ignoré ce qui me
choque c'est que l'état prend des
engagements
il ya un vote à l'assemblée nationale et
la continuité ne ce n'est pas assurée a
dit on ignore ce qui a été décidé au
parlement il ya pas très longtemps